famous last words are notorious for not
being able to predict the future well
but they do convey our inner World
magnificently
my name is Natasha and I lead an
innovation consultancy called blumline
where we study people and culture to
design smarter Kinder wiser futures
my shelter in place did not include any
sourdough or much sleep but it did
include working with the healthcare
Innovation Community to try to prop up
the system with covid-19 response
through the design thinking lens
we rapidly created a brand and recruited
volunteers for PPE challenges masks
blood donation but the real challenge
was the rising death toll and the end of
life which was really at the center of
the entire pandemic
front line
caregivers were required to make
decisions for people they had barely met
and required to resuscitate even when it
would cause irreparable harm which most
people didn't know coming in without
advanced directives
the team and I worked on uncovering
insights and we realized that a journey
map was really the best way to tell this
story to illustrate to people the
pathway of what happens when you get
coveted and you go into the hospital
become intubated and are likely
unconscious it's not the best way to
advocate for yourself or your agency
and a lot of this wasn't tremendously
unfamiliar working with chronic
conditions and behavior change
but we had a unique Moment In Time the
pandemic actually created an opening we
call it a Moment of Truth where
possibility
um
can become a reality but people still
need Solutions so we created one called
famous last words
that was set in three parts life death
and dying and it was a collective
self-discovery ritual
which means looking at self and values
first but in the company of other people
where we can actually learn relational
Dynamics
about burial
mycelium suit
the ash Cannon by Hunter S Thompson and
Tibetan Sky rituals all examples of more
creative ways of thinking about the end
of life which is something that we don't
usually do we usually avoid it
and treat it as something to fight
against
for me this was motivated by my
grandmother whose end of life wishes I
know very well she has multiple dnrs
plastered all over her house
but her emotional side is a little
harder I think she has a hard time
understanding that she might have a
right to think more creatively about
aging
care comes in many forms like the warm
water glove and the Brazilian ICU that
comforted a covid patient or the
Butterfly Kisses for a cancer patient
that were attracted by orange juice
exploring different cultures
in different settings is essential you
know we can participate in revelry
or we can talk about death through the
medical system through paperwork which
sounds super fun
or we can bring Beauty and
Rouse courage through that
and bring the mystical back into our
experience
it isn't by avoiding death that we get
more comfortable with it
it's by confronting it but in a generous
way not in a deaf porn sense
and one of the best questions I find for
this is asking who is the you of now
because certainly none of us are who we
were three years ago
and thank goodness
I'm not
sometimes you walk through a portal you
don't even see coming and that's the
beauty of thinking about Futures we just
don't know
it makes it difficult to think about
death because we write things like final
wishes
but nothing's final we have to come back
to it again and again we have to slow
down
and we have to be willing to revisit it
and to go into spaces that can teach us
more than we think they can
so I encourage you
to explore Collective self-discovery
with me
and let me know how you're getting
creative
[Applause]